it's a tuesday edition of pftot just six
days until pft live is back on nbc
sports radio and nbc sn plenty of things
still happening though in the nfl
training camps opening and the nfl
taking care of business on friday we
found out that chief's receiver tyreek
hill would not be suspended as a result
of multiple potential violations of the
personal conduct policy for which he was
investigated coincidentally or not the
nfl held until the next business day the
news that seahawks defensive lineman
geron reid would be suspended six games
under the personal conduct policy even
though he wasn't arrested wasn't charged
but the nfl decided he had violated the
personal conduct policy as a result of a
domestic violence incident now the
problem with this
and this really speaks to the heart of
the nfl's investigative procedures and
the power the nfl has or more accurately
doesn't have to get the information that
it needs in reed's case i'm told that
the alleged victim cooperated with the
nfl if the victim says i'm not
cooperating good luck getting the
information that you need in order to
come to the conclusion that a violation
of the personal conduct policy has
occurred and that's what happened in
hill's case because the underlying child
abuse investigation involves a minor
there's an exception to the open records
law in kansas and the johnson county
kansas prosecutor was able to tell the
nfl we're not giving you any evidence
we're not giving you any documents so
the nfl had no opportunity to delve into
the details as to what did or didn't
happen and who was or wasn't suspected
and remember the prosecutor in tyreek
hill's case said back in april that he
believes a crime was committed against
tyra kill's three-year-old son the
prosecutor just didn't believe he could
prove who actually did it so there's
evidence there somewhere of something
happening to this child but in hill's
case the nfl couldn't get to it in jaron
reid's case the nfl could and i think
that
more than anything else should prompt
the nfl to take a step back and say
why are we doing this why are we trying
to be our own police force and justice
system when we lack the powers of a
police force or justice system it's one
thing if you're investigating wrongdoing
among nfl employees or team employees
and there's a way to compel people who
are on the payroll to cooperate but they
have no power over people who are
disconnected from the nfl and that's why
there was such a discrepancy between
hill and reed and i think that's why the
nfl held reed's decision held the news
of the suspension until monday it would
have been too glaring if it had come out
on the same day that we found out that
tyree kill was not going to be suspended
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports